dieser Ansatz hat sich ganz klar gezeigt
bei der Umsetzung des sogenannten
getreideabkommens abgeschlossen unter
der Mitwirkung des un-sekretariats das
darauf abzielte die globale
Lebensmittelsicherheit zu gewährleistet
der Reduzierung der Gefahr einer
Hungerkrise und der Hilfe für die
ärmsten Länder unter anderem auch in
Afrika aber in fast einem Jahr wurden im
Rahmen des sogenannten Abkommens aus der
Ukraine insgesamt
32,8 Millionen Tonnen Fracht exportiert
davon sind über 70% liebe Freunde in die
Länder mit einem hohen Einkommen gelangt
dazu gehören
auch Länder der Europäischen Union aber
solche Länder wie Äthiopien Sudan
Somalia und eine Reihe weiterer Länder
sie haben unter drei Prozent abbekommen
vom Gesamtvolumen
das ist weniger als eine Millionen ein
eine Million Tonnen russland hat sich
auf dieses sogenannte Abkommen
eingelassen weil dort Verpflichtungen
enthalten waren dass die unrechtmäßigen
Hindernisse abgelehnt werden dass wir
unser Getreide auch auf die Weltmärkte
liefern dürfen und ich kann Ihnen sagen
dass auch hier und in erster Linie
hierin die Hilfe an die ärmsten Länder
liegt aber in Wahrheit passierte nichts
davon was wir besprochen hatten und was
uns versprochen wurde keine einzige
Bedingung
der Sanktion Verpflichtungen bei den
Getreide Lieferungen auf die Weltmärkte
wurden erfüllt keine Bedingung die
Hindernis Ruhe dann auch in den Weg
gelegt für die unentgeltlichen
Getreidelieferungen nach Afrika das
haben wir mit Afrikanischen Union
besprochen das gilt auch für Mineral
Dünger für die Ärmsten länger von 262
Tonnen Düngemittel wurden blockiert in
den Häfen und wir konnten nur zwei
Chargen liefern 20.000 Tonnen nach
Malawi
und der Rest 34 Tonnen nach Kenia der
Rest blieb in den Händen der Europäer
ungeachtet der Tatsache dass wir hier
von einer humanitären Aktion besprochen
hatten für die ist ja gar keine
Sanktionen geben darf naja gut jemand
möchte nicht dass Russland wie einige
gesagt sich bereichert und Geld für
Kriegsziele ausgibt aber das ist doch
eine unentgeltliche Lieferung nein sie
haben es nicht freigegeben ungeachtet
versprechen dass sie den Ärmsten helfen
wollen unter Berücksichtigung der
Faktoren haben wir den weiteren Verlauf
des Deals abgelehnt wir möchten das
ukrainische Getreide ersetzen
kommerziell aber auch unentgeltlich weil
wir den Bedürftigsten Ländern Afrikas
helfen wollen in diesem Jahr erwarten
wir wieder einmal eine Rekordernte
um hier ganz konkret zu sein füge ich
hinzu und kann Ihnen sagen wir sind
bereit schon in den nächsten Monaten
drei bis vier Monaten nämlich
unentgeltlich an Burkina Faso Simbabwe
Mali Somalia die Zentralafrikanische
Republik und Eritrea Zulieferern
[Applaus]
Getreide wir werden auch eine kostenlose
Lieferung dieser Produktion an die
Verbraucher gewährleisten
[Applaus]
wahrscheinlich sind noch weitere Zahlen
interessant im letzten
landwirtschaftlichen Jahr hat die
Ukraine etwa 55 Millionen Tonnen
Getreide produziert der Export betrug 47
Millionen Tonnen nicht wenig davon 17
Millionen
Tonnen war Weizen russland hat aber
verehrte Kollegen im letzten Jahr 156
Millionen Tonnen eingefahren 60 davon 60
Millionen Tonnen wurden exportiert davon
sind 48 Millionen Tonnen Weizen der
Anteil Russland auf dem Weltmarkt für
Weizen beträgt 20 % der Ukraine unter 5
das heißt es ist Russland das hier einen
großen Beitrag liefert für die
Lebensmittelsicherheit und ein
verantwortungsvoller globaler Lieferant
von Agrarprodukten und diejenigen die
behaupten
das ist nicht so ist dass es nicht
stimmt und das nur das getreideabkommen
dazu einen Beitrag leistet diejenigen
verdrehen die Tatsachen sie sagen
Unwahrheiten naja im Grunde haben wir
das ja in den letzten Jahrzehnten
vielleicht sogar Jahrhunderten gesehen
das ist die gängige Praxis von einigen
westlichen Ländern unser Land wird auch
weiterhin durch unsere humanitären
Lieferung die Bedürftigen Regionen und
Länder unterstützen wir möchten ganz
aktiv daran beteiligt sein ein
gerechteres System der
Ressourcenverteilung zu gewährleisten
wir sind maximal bemüht die globale
Lebensmittelkrise abzuwenden im Grunde
sind wir überzeugt wenn wir
entsprechende Agrar Technologie nutzen
und auch die landwirtschaftliche
Produktion gut organisieren dann wird
die Afrika nicht nur sich selbst
ernähren können sondern auch
selbstständig die eigene
Lebensmittelsicherheit gewährleisten und
kann auch zum Exporteur werden von
Lebensmitteln und seitens Russland
werden wir Ihnen nur Unterstützung
zukommen lassen das kann ich Ihnen
versprechen
ja fragen wir mal nach in Afrika in
Nairobi bei Norbert Haan wie stark und
wie verlässlich ist denn das Engagement
Putins oder Russlands in Afrika
eigentlich
ja da muss man glaube ich unterscheiden
welches Engagement man meint das
politische Engagement Russlands ist
relativ groß das wirtschaftliche auch da
wird versucht also ich würde sagen diese
beiden Punkte betreffen die meisten
Länder Afrikas dann gibt es noch das
militärische Engagement da sind wir bei
einer Handvoll von Ländern und bei denen
ist es Engagement Russland tatsächlich
dann groß das sind alles Länder die sich
schon auch ein Stück weit von Russland
abhängig gemacht haben zuletzt zu nennen
Mali aber auch die zentrale afrikanische
Republik wo militärisch und
wirtschaftlich wirklich Hand in Hand
gehen ja das sind auch die Frage der
Verlässlichkeit oder auch der
Nachhaltigkeit und man kann es
vielleicht oder kann man es ablesen an
der Teilnahme an diesem Gipfel in St
Petersburg das nicht alle Staatschefs
angereist sind
ja daran kann man sicherlich einiges
ablesen also ich glaube man kann man
kann beide Seiten ablesen zum einen sind
nach russischen Angaben ja 49
afrikanische Länder vertreten das ist ja
fast der ganze Kontinent
vor ein paar Jahren als es den ersten
Russland Afrika Gipfel gegeben hat da
sind auch fast alle stadtschefs und
Staatsoberhäupter angereist und diesmal
haben wir nicht mal die Hälfte davon
also man sieht da ran schon dass das ist
schon auch ein Statement und das heißt
nicht dass alle Russland lieben viele
Länder wollen einfach nur den Kontakt
aufrecht erhalten wollen sich in einer
Welt die sich verwandelt die multipolar
geworden ist wollen sie sich eben nicht
mit Russland komplett verscherzen und
würden gerne auch in notfallskostenloses
Getreide entgegennehmen auch wenn es
geklaut ist aus der Ukraine verfängt das
in irgendeiner Weise hat das eine
Nachhaltigkeit eine positive Wirkung für
Russland für Putin
also erstmal glaube ich geht es darum
dass das Getreide überhaupt kommt ob das
jetzt kommen wird das müssen wir noch
sehen es reicht ja nicht das Putin des
verspricht sondern die Ausführung muss
ja auch da sein also kann ja das alleine
machen braucht er wieder Partner wie die
Türkei
es wird jetzt gerade viel geredet über
einen neuen Deal mit der Türkei
die Türkei die dann womöglich für die
Logistik sorgen würde und auch mit Katha
das womöglich Geld gibt um um diese
Logistik zu finanzieren das ist alles
nicht bestätigt aber man sieht daran
dass es nicht nur allein um Putin geht
sondern es geht auch darum und was er
verspricht wie viel Getreide er
verspricht und wie will ich ja das
verspricht sondern auch wie wir das am
Ende wirklich umsetzen und was ich ganz
interessant fand an seiner Rede war er
hat ja auch schon die Länder genannt die
er sozusagen kostenfrei halten will und
das sind tatsächlich die wo Russland
massiv
massiv vertreten ist massiv engagiert
ist auch militärisch engagiert ist
zentralafrikanisch Republik Mali auch
Burkina Faso hat ja genannt also und
Eritrea das sogenannte Nordkorea Afrikas
das diktatorisch regierte Eritrea das
sind die Länder die er da irgendwie im
Auge hat und das
das zeigt eigentlich auch schon dass er
Getreide dass er Nahrung als in gewisser
Weise als Waffe einsetzt oder zumindest
als diplomatisches Mittel
wir müssen natürlich wenn wir schon über
Afrika sprechen auch über die sehr
sprechen und den Putsch dort wie es
aktuell die Situation und sowas führt
das ganze
ja ich glaube wozu das Ganze führt das
lässt sich so genau noch gar nicht sagen
die Situation ist im Moment die dass
tatsächlich das Militär die Regierung
übernommen hat und wir wissen aber nicht
im Grunde was die Agenda des Militärs
ist als Gründe wurden ja genannt die
schlechte Regierungsführung vom
Präsidenten
Mohammed bazoom
wirtschaftliche Probleme auch Probleme
mit der Sicherheit natürlich es gibt da
Islamismus in sehr der Armee fällt es
schwer der Gewalt her zu werden also das
alles wurde eben wurde eben angeführt ob
das die waren Gründe sind das wissen wir
nicht und wir wissen vor allen Dingen
auch nicht wie die Militär unter jetzt
tickt also ob sie so denkt wie die
nachbardiktaturen jetzt in Burkina Faso
und auch in Mali wo der Westen ja
teilweise oder in Mali ganz
rausgeschmissen worden ist oder
rausgeschmissen wird
das wissen wir alles nicht und das wird
natürlich ein Einfluss haben auf
Europa und es wird ein Einfluss haben
auch auf Deutschland und auf die
Bundeswehr die ja aus Mali abziehen will
und dafür den luftschutzpunkt in die
Armee in die sehr braucht aber dann
herzlichen Dank für die Vorstellung
Informationen Einschätzungen aus Nairobi
danke schön dorthin